Mittlerweile ist die völker. Nein so weit optimiert dass es zack auf zack gehen könnte landen auftanken
Und innerhalb von 24 stunden wieder abheben die. Kosten für den. Raketenstart sollen zeitnah. Noch weiter gesenkt werden damit rückt mass version
Visionen immer näher die besiedlung. Anderer planeten was kann die neue version der folgen einer rakete möglich
Und hat spacex damit tatsächlich eine zeitenwende im weltraum, eingeleitet danke für diesen hammer themenvorschlag von
Euch bei den messengern und herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction und den iren mass chroniken
Kurz noch mal in eigener sache die abo box ist ja für viele youtuber ein graus und sie würden immer größer
Ihr habt einfach keine möglichkeit sicherzustellen dass. Ihr erfahrt wenn. Ein
neues video online geht und das gilt auch in abgeschwächter form für die glocke deshalb meine bitte an
Mich und vor allem in eurem interesse folgt mehr auf whatsapp oder den anderen messengern nur da verpasst ja garantiert kein video. Mehr
Ja wir reden hier immer wieder über ihren maske und seinen raumfahrtunternehmen spacex
Eines seiner größten eine seiner größten schöpfung ist wohl die falcon 9 rakete
Ja sowohl der. Amazon chef bezos als auch in de mars. Wollen die
Kolonisierung des sonnensystems ermöglichen massen, big felken rocket die bfa. So etwa in vier. Jahren zum ersten
Mal bemannte raumflüge im inneren sonnensystem möglich machen beide männer kann man. Tatsächlich als pioniere bezeichnen, denn
Sie, arbeiten daran verkehrsmittel zu konzipieren die eines tages massen an menschen in den weltraum befördern könnten im mai dieses
jahres, erfolgte dazu der nächste schritt mit der falken ein block von
Spacex war zum ersten mal überhaupt eine rakete gestartet die. Ohne aufwändige instandsetzung erneut abheben. Konnte
Und noch vor ihrem start hatte elenas. Keinen preis für die rakete der den
Preis für die rakete von 62 millionen us dollar auf 50 millionen gesenkt der volle preis ist nur von denen
Noch, zu zahlen die eine komplett neue felgen. Einbestellen ja und langfristig planas die kosten immer weiter
Zu senken bis der preis irgendwann bei 5 millionen dollar pro start league möglich wäre das wenn die
Meisten bestandteile der rakete wieder verwendet werden werden und diese diese angepeilte preis ist echt. Wow, denn
Der preis einer vergleichbaren ariane-5 von arianespace als europa. Dafür müssen, interessenten etwa
180 millionen us dollar hinlegen
Wirtschaftlich gesehen klingt das auf den ersten blick vielleicht choreo form sollte mast alle anderen konkurrenten noch weiter, unterbieten wenn
Er doch eh schon mit abstand den. Besten preis anbietet aber wie eben schon
Gesagt was langfristige pläne sind es menschen ins all zu bringen und das in etwa
So alltäglich zu machen wie wenn wir uns, heutzutage mit aller selbstverständlichkeit. Ein
taxi rufen
Um von a nach b zu kommen, er ist von seiner sache fest folgt damit die menschheit den dritten weltkrieg
überleben kann muss es möglich sein auf anderen planeten zu siedeln oder stephen hawking meinte ja
um die klimakatastrophe zu überleben eine reise zum mars soll mass vision zufolge schon in wenigen
Jahren, erschwinglich sein artikel soll demnach 100.000 us dollar. Kosten ja alles fing im juni vor acht. Jahren an
2010 damals war die erste völkern eine rakete gestartet seitdem wurde sie immer weiter
Optimiert jetzt hat die rakete fast die doppelte masse und kann zudem
Mehr als die doppelte nutzlast transportieren der große punkt die raketen sind ja wieder verwendbar. Und zwar ziemlich. Komplett die felgen
ein block 5 ist laut basics die endgültige version der rakete
Bis dann etwa 2020 die bfa
Folgen soll im mai war die völker. Neuen indien arbeit gestartet. Und hatte den ersten satelliten
April, liefert der für bangladesch gestartet war das ziel ist eine flugpause von nur
24 stunden in diesem zeitraum soll aufgetankt werden und die nutzlast befestigt werden eine
Generalüberholung gibt es erst nach ungefähr zehn flügen das heißt jetzt wurden, alle bauteile
So optimiert dass das zum ersten mal in der geschichte der raumfahrt möglich ist zu den größten veränderungen an der rakete gehören beispielsweise
Das verschraubte ob diese struktur an der die. Neuen triebwerke befestigt werden wird bei dieser
Neuen version nicht mehr verschweißt so fällt eine aufwändige
Inspektion der schweißnähte weg und neu konstruiert zudem ist der hitzeschild am rand der unteren stufe
Er muss jetzt nicht mehr lackiert werden wertvolle. Zeit wird also gespart
preiswerte raketen braucht ihnen was aber noch aus einem anderen grund denn bis ins jahr 2027 will er mehr als
4400 satelliten in flache umlaufbahn bringen
langfristiges ziel sind weitere
7000 die dann alle einen superschnellen internetzugang weltweit
Ermöglichen sollen zehn milliarden us dollar werden für die platzierung der satelliten kalkuliert weitere
kosten für wartung sind da noch nicht eingerechnet
Und genau das ist mass zweites motiv für seinen plan preiswerte staat kosten für raketen möglich zu machen, um das nächste
Riesengeschäft zu starten viele andere. Unternehmer sind an solchen mammut projekten gescheitert was bisher noch nicht wenn
Er kein video zu ihrem us raketenpläne, zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet
Mich bei whatsapp
Und den anderen messenger nur dann verpasst er kein video die abo box auf youtube user immer ziemlich
Lückenhaft über die messenger erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Einfach hier draufklicken
Und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines goodie. Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks, um social media abonnieren da erfahrt
Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt aktuell die anhörung von mark zuckerberg vor dem europäischen parlament
dafür hier klicken und nicht die glocke vergessen
Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken dem start der falcon heavy live hier auf dich zum ja das war der absolute wahnsinn
Wer es noch nicht gesehen hat ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran